say the line
here's some new sunscreen reviews
yay!
it's michelle of lab muffin
beauty science chemistry phd
cosmetic chemist and sunscreen connoisseur
stylekorean asked me to review a bunch of popular
korean sunscreens for this sponsored video
because most of you are heading into summer in
the northern hemisphere and they've kindly put
all of the sunscreens i'm
talking about today on sale
all the links are in the description
if you want to check them out
conveniently i'm heading out of summer so i've
actually been trying out tons of sunscreens
and there are some really nice
ones in this batch including a
few that you've probably seen
hyped up tons on social media
i firmly believe that there is the perfect
sunscreen out there for everyone but it can
be a bit of a journey to get there my top tips for
buying sunscreens that you will probably enjoy are
firstly check out reviews from people
with a similar skin type as yours
my skin is oily and dehydration prone
and also pretty prone to clogged pores
and hyperpigmentation if your skin is
similar there is a good chance that we'll
like similar sunscreens and probably
similar skin care products in general
tip number two i really recommend writing
down a list of sunscreen needs and wants
and every time you come across
a sunscreen that sounds good
check it against every item on that list this is
a really good way of making sure you don't get
swept up in the hype and completely
forget about a massive dealbreaker
if there's a sunscreen that you don't like for
your face then don't forget that you can still use
it up on your neck your hands and the rest of
your body i think us skincare nerds tend to forget
about everything below about here so it is a good
way to show some love to the poor neglected areas
i also made a video recently answering all of the
common questions that i get about sunscreens so
make sure you check that video out as well
onto our sunscreens
i'm going to start with my favorite because
i am not good at keeping the good things
until the end the beauty of joseon
relief sun rice and probiotics
this is a sunscreen that's spf 50 plus and pa
with four pluses which is as high as you can
go for spf and uva protection in korea the spf
rating has been certified by two separate labs
in korea and spain testing in two different labs
in two different countries was one of the ways i
recommended for getting a reliable spf rating
in my video on the spf apocalypse of late 2020
so it's nice to see this being done and this info
being shared publicly this sunscreen is made by
kolmar a big sunscreen manufacturer in korea that
has a great reputation for making really effective
sunscreens in fact all four of the sunscreens i'm
talking about today are manufactured by kolmar
they've become really popular post spf-pocalypse
i think a lot of brands have become rightfully
nervous about their sunscreen formulations which
makes perfect sense all four sunscreens are also
actually approved and sold as uv protective
sunscreen functional cosmetics in korea
although they're not approved in the us
or australia or a bunch of other countries
odile monod talks a lot about the korean beauty
industry on her channel and to make sure your
korean sunscreen is actually approved in korea she
recommends checking two things firstly that the
term functional cosmetic shows up on both the
tube and on the box of the sunscreen secondly
that it's actually sold in korea so for example
you can look up the korean website of the brand
and check that it's available there i've checked
this for all four of the sunscreens i'm talking
about today out of them the beauty of joseon
sunscreen is my favorite this is a chemical
sunscreen with newer filters and it has a
very nice light texture like a hydrating
gel moisturizer it's not greasy at all it sinks
into skin very quickly and it is very hydrating
this sunscreen has very little white cast
it doesn't show up on glow by ramon who
has medium-ish brown skin but it can show up on
moderately darker skin tones like @glowskinguy's
even though it is a chemical or organic
sunscreen it has mbbt in it which is an
insoluble organic filter and those solid particles
can sometimes give a white cast on skin that's on
the darker side it has no fragrance and no
alcohol if those are problems for your skin
and it's designed to be super cosmetically
elegant and it works really well under makeup
it's also designed to wash off easily which
is great if you're worried about clogged pores
but it does mean that it's not going
to stay nicely spread out on your skin
if you're sweating or moving around a
lot so keep that in mind when you use it
the key skincare ingredient in here is rice
which is a pretty popular ingredient in korean
skin care it's meant to be great for hydration
and for sensitive skin the packaging says it
has 30% rice extract and a 1000 ppm rice germ
extract as well as three probiotic rice ferments
there are also a bunch of other plant extracts
in there as well along with niacinamide which
is great for soothing skin and helping with
brightening there's also glycerin which is
an incredible hydrating humectant which is
one of my favorites and adenosine which is
an anti-wrinkle active beauty of joseon has some
other products that i really like as well they
have a great cleansing balm and a bunch of nice
serums with a mix of traditional korean hanbang
ingredients like ginseng rice propolis as well
as more modern ingredients like niacinamide
and snail mucin i recommend checking them out
if you're in the market for some new products
mary & may cica soothing sun cream is next and
this seems to be a very similar formula to the
beauty of chosen sunscreen it has the same
sunscreen actives and base ingredients in a
similar order but different skincare
ingredients and a touch of fragrance
mary & may is a brand i haven't heard of
before but they're a clean korean brand
with a core brand philosophy of being 16 free
and using only ewg green grade ingredients
ewg green grade seems to be a pretty common claim
for korean products now i'm guessing what it means
is that all of the ingredients are rated at three
or below in the ewgs completely unscientific and
pretty darn arbitrary rating system i've talked
about why clean beauty is bs before in this video
anyway as you'd expect this has a very similar
texture to the beauty of joseon sunscreen
the differences are mostly with the
skincare ingredients as well as a light
slightly floral fragrance that goes away pretty
quickly after you apply it it's been tested to
be hypoallergenic and like the beauty of joseon
sunscreen it's formulated to work really well
under makeup as an everyday commuter sunscreen
in terms of the skincare ingredients the beauty
of joseon sunscreen focuses on rice whereas this
focuses on centella which you probably guessed
from the cica name centella is great for soothing
sensitive skin i love using cica products when my
skin is irritated and needs a bit of nourishment
this sun cream has ten thousand parts per million
or one percent f cica complex which has seven
different centella extracts and fermented yeast
it's meant to be soothing and hydrating it also
has niacinamide and adenosine which is why this
is also a whitening and anti-aging functional
cosmetic in korea on top of being a sunscreen i
talked about this ingredient pairing before in my
heimish video the beauty of joseon sunscreen has
this niacinamide and adenosine pairing too but it
doesn't have this extra functional cosmetic claim
i'm not sure why but it could explain why the mary
& may sunscreen has a higher regular retail price
next up we have the isntree hyaluronic acid
watery sun gel i've talked about this before
this is a chemical organic sunscreen with a
relatively heavier texture compared to a lot
of korean sunscreens it's super popular it has no
white cast no fragrance and no alcohol and it's
recommended for dry and sensitive skin like the
other two it's spf 50 plus and pa with four pluses
and also like a lot of other korean sunscreens now
they have the independent testing on their site to
verify these ratings and this one has it from the
korean institute of dermatological science this
is also proved as a whitening and anti-wrinkle
functional cosmetic again because it's got that
niacinamide and adenosine combo on top of that
this also has eight types of hyaluronic acid
hyaluronic acid is used in skin care as a
humectant that grabs onto water and keeps it on
and in your skin but a lot of people complain
that it can feel like it dries your skin out
i think this is because a lot of products use only
one size of hyaluronic acid so it all might stay
on the surface of your skin and it feels like it
dries into a film to avoid these a lot of products
including this one now use a range of sizes of
hyaluronic acid to hydrate your skin at different
depths so it feels a bit more like well-rounded
hydration there are a bunch of other skincare
ingredients in this as well like astaxanthin
centella and ceramide the isntree website
recommends this for outdoor activities but it
isn't officially water resistant so i don't think
you should rely on this for like hardcore exercise
but i do think it is probably going to hold up
better to movement and sweat compared to your
average korean sunscreen this is also recommended
for reapplication over makeup which i've talked
about before i recommend using a cushion puff
sponge for this it's also been tested for skin
irritation and it passed with flying colors
unfortunately on their page they also show
ewg ratings for every ingredient in it which
i thought we moved past as a species as well as
the sunscreen infographic that's not quite right
it says chemical sunscreens need 30
minutes to absorb before working which is
a bit silly because it's not true and this is a
chemical sunscreen so they're pointing out a fake
disadvantage for their own product they also show
a video of it absorbing uv immediately under uv
camera so yeah don't think that chemical
sunscreens need a longer waiting time
they have the same waiting time as a physical
sunscreen you just need it to dry down and form a
nice continuous layer that doesn't move around too
much before you go out into the sun i quite like
the sunscreen even though it's recommended for
sensitive and dry skin and my skin is oily isntree
also have a stick sunscreen that's recommended
for oily skin that i'm pretty keen to try as well
the last sunscreen i'm talking about today is
the innisfree intensive long-lasting sunscreen
ex i had to try that three times that is a tongue
twister i'm pretty excited about this one because
like the rest of the sunscreens this is spf
50 plus pa with four pluses but the special
bit is that it's actually water resistant it's
recommended for surfing and playing in the water
thanks to odile monod again my korean beauty
insider info guru water resistant in korea
means that the spf drops by less than 20% after 40
minutes in water during that water resistance test
this is less strict than the australian and the us
standards they need the sunscreen to stay at the
full spf after water exposure but it is stricter
than the eu one which lets it drop to half the spf
i'm pretty sure this is the first water
resistant korean sunscreen that i've ever tried
unsurprisingly it is quite heavy
in texture for korean sunscreen
but it is a lot lighter than a typical
western water resistant sunscreen
sunscreens that are water resistant usually
have a lot of polymers and thicker oilier
ingredients to keep it in place when your
skin gets wet so you usually end up with
more of a noticeable feeling on your face this is
a pretty unique sunscreen in my sunscreen library
it works well for those in between
situations where you might want a smoother
lighter sunscreen that sits nicely under makeup
but you're also going to get like a bit moist
like maybe you're going on a boat ride at a
wedding or something i don't know your life
i really like that korea has a standard for
their water resistant label there are a few
japanese sunscreens i've tried that i really liked
that claim to be water resistant but unfortunately
as far as i know there isn't a standard for water
resistance in japan so unless the brand describes
how they tested their claim you just don't really
know how much you can rely on that if you have
recommendations for water resistant korean
sunscreens please leave them in the comments
so this is a combination sunscreen that uses a
mix of both organic and inorganic uv filters it
has a slight white cast that mostly goes away as
the sunscreen settles down i would expect that
this might not be great for dark skin tones i'm
guessing that white cast is from the zinc oxide
and or the titanium dioxide this sunscreen doesn't
have alcohol in it and it has a hydrating feel
with a slightly oily finish that's a bit more
noticeable than with other korean sunscreens
the scent is floral and moderately strong which
innisfree says is from a low allergen fragrance
based on the reviews i found online most people
don't have eye sting with this but a few people do
eye sting is quite individual and
not everyone gets stinging from
the same products and ingredients so
for most people this is probably fine
one last thing i do have to mention this coral
reef friendly logo because it is on the front
i am not a fan of this label especially coming
from a product that i'm pretty sure isn't being
sold near any coral reefs i've talked a lot
about this whole reef safe marketing in previous
videos but the concentrations of sunscreens that
were found to damage corals and studies so far
are well below the concentrations that have been
measured in the wild the ocean is massive and it
mixes around a lot so sunscreen washing off into
the ocean really doesn't seem like a big issue
compared to everything else that coral reefs are
facing unless you are basically touching the coral
here it just seems to mean that it just
doesn't have oxybenzone and octinoxate
those are the two ingredients that were banned
in hawaii following a study that was pushed
very heavily in the media but this sunscreen
actually does have nano zinc oxide and nano
titanium dioxide which were both found to damage
coal at again unrealistically high concentrations
i don't think the evidence shows that it's a real
issue for any sunscreen ingredient but i think if
you're a brand using that in your marketing you
should be holding it to a consistent standard
they did recently change their packaging to
a white tube without this reef logo so that's
pretty encouraging so keep that new packaging
in mind as well if you have trouble finding this
all of these sunscreens are on sale at star korean
at the moment the links are in the description
make sure you check them out if you're looking
for a new sunscreen if you found this video useful
click the like and please consider subscribing
and joining the nerdification squad also make sure
you check out my other videos on sunscreen and
skincare which should be popping up next to me now